être un animateur télé n'est pas
toujours un long fleuve tranquille si de
l'extérieur on peut imaginer que c'est
plutôt la belle vie dès que les
audiences baissent que le public
s'éloigne que les patrons de chaînes
vous on en disgrâce la chute peut
s'avérer très douloureuse c'est de ces
difficultés de durée dont christophe
dechavanne décidé de parler invité de
stéphane bern sur rtl hier matin
l'animateur producteur est revenu sur la
dure réalité du métier d'animateur fut
un temps lorsque j'étais à l'antenne je
n'en parle même pas je recevais entre 4
600 voeux par par an et auquel je me
faisais fort pendant plusieurs jours de
repos personnellement je connais jean
noël kouici n'est plus à l'antenne de
tf1 depuis plusieurs mois déjà
cette absence n'est pas anodine pour lui
et malgré sa longue carrière et son
expérience solide cette période semble
très difficile à gérer une dure réalité
à laquelle de nombreux animateurs ont dû
faire face dans leur carrière avant
d'attendre de rebondir mais changer de
vie est aussi un choix possible c'est
par exemple ce qu'a fait vincent lagaf
qui a monté une entreprise de jet ski
même chose pour laurent fontaine membre
du mythique duo bataille et fontaine qui
est aujourd'hui devenu conseiller en
communication de son côté text a
retrouvé une seconde jeunesse sur scène
loin des plateaux télé alors selon vous
licenciement hypocrisie mise au placard
le monde de la télé et il sans pitié qui
va nous faire énormément réagir je vous
le dis et c'est vrai que christophe
dechavanne a lancé le sujet alors vous
dites oui bah c'est dingue parce que et
c'est tous les animateurs et mine de
rien qui disent oui et tous ceux qui
sont pas vraiment animateur c'est en
voyant leur métier 10 nous c'est assez
symptomatique alors toi et pas pour vous
valérie bénaïm séoul pour oui j'espère
simplement bannir et en plus vous avez
moi j'ai su plaire séduire et oui c'est
moi j'ai du bol parce que je suis bénie
des dieux j'ai une traversée du désert
mais c'est là où on se rend compte quand
on est donc se rend pas compte
effectivement parce que tout va bien
tout le monde vous saurez tout le monde
est absolument charmant et évidemment on
ne vous dit pas les choses en face parce
que par définition vous pouvez
éventuellement prendre quelqu'un comme
chroniqueur éventuellement faire une
émission donc on ne sait jamais donc on
est absolument charmant avec vous mais
alors je dis pas que c'est plus ou moins
qu'une autre qu un autre monde de
l'entreprise c'est une entreprise la
télé alors comme on ne voit que les
paillettes comme on ne voit que les
choses qui font qu'ils sont formidables
parce qu'on est célèbre
c'est génial on gagne de l'argent c'est
formidable mais on peut pas non plus
nier que c'est une entreprise qui est
dur parce que un matin vous êtes en haut
le lendemain pour mettre en bas et
parfois elle est injuste c'est à dire
que vous pouvez être en haut alors que
vous n'êtes pas très très bon et vous
pouvez être en bas alors que vous êtes
très bon c'est pas forcément corrélé
avec la
talent vous en avez souffert vous
valérie dit l'amérique eux alors moi
j'ai de la chance c'est que très
honnêtement la télé fait partie de ma
vie mais c'est pas ma vie donc quand
est-ce que vous avez exercé sur france 3
un moment j'ai eu une traversée du
désert donné quatre ans 84 ans est alors
4e mais moi je bats moi j'ai joué j'ai
mangé quoi journaliste donc j'ai écrit
des livres
l'accord écrit des livres en sortir
financièrement bah c'est autre chose
c'est différent c'est d'essayer il
devait changer votre mode de vie
non parce que je suis pas une flambeuse
donc je vais j'avais été très naïfs
attention voilà mais comme un malheur
entre guillemets n'arrive jamais seule
c'est au moment où également que je me
suis où je me suis séparé donc et avec
un montrant chambardement dans ma vie
mais voilà alors c'est qu'on va pas
faire pleurer dans les chaumières parce
que quand on ça fonctionne bien on gagne
beaucoup d'argent mais ça reste un monde
où effectivement combien de la paillette
sur la au dessus ou en dessous de la
paillette si on gratte un peu
ja il n'y a pas de pitié il ya
d'hypocrisie et il ya une grande cruauté
d'alors mais jean michel maire vous dit
non
oui mais ça m'étonne pas du tout que ce
soit que des animateurs qui sont du côté
oui les caliméros parce qu'il faut
vraiment arrêter d'en finir celui-là
souvent je peux animateur je peux parler
fait d'avoir été le co nul vraiment
d'entreprises rencontrent c'est bien
plus dur et quelle est la télévision
c'est une vraie chance tu travailles
beaucoup moins que dans la brève dans
une vraie entreprise
j'ai été au figaro tu veux dire % chez
un vrai fignon j'ai travaillé beaucoup
plus qu'ici voilà tpiy beaucoup moins
ici tu as beaucoup davantage de
notoriété que c'était donc de se
plaindre de la le monde de la télévision
c'est sûr quand tu te plat quand ça
s'arrête
est ce que tu es tellement bien au
soleil quand ça va bien mais quand tu
vas dans l'ombre
la séquence est dans le soleil de
téléphone est ce que tu vois ce que j'ai
dit tu as entendu une complainte
entendue une plainte parce que oui
c'était serre sur l'assaut du tout c'est
cruel
j'ai pas dis hou la la jab l'entreprise
est cruel l'entreprise et calalou jeudi
7 ans et arman est toujours fermé au
mcee stadler je vais aller dans le sens
de valérie mois ils sont quand le
travail en sont pas des ris sur
célébrités à cette époque là elle était
enceinte
effectivement elle avait pris un peu de
poids très bien de ce café tf1 et ce
qu'ils m'ont dit à l'époque je dirais
pas la personne idoine est d'une cruauté
absolue qui sont directement en bas
qu'elle aimait trop grossi qu'elle était
horrible à l'antenne qu'il fallait la
sortir
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui est arrivé me
sens bleu et blanc c'est moi qui suis
parent ne sais pas si j'ai écouté ce
qu'ils ont dit oui je vous avais tempête
allez allez allez rory est horrible
mieux lorsque donc j'ai été moi j'ai
travaillé
première femme enceinte à la télévision
et moi j'avais jamais dit ce n'est pas
une maladie
donc je le montre je ne suis pas malade
donc je vais jusqu'au terme
et en l'occurrence effectivement j'avais
pris du poids parce que je sais que
j'étais une femme enceinte
donc moi j'ai été jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
1/8 mois jusqu'au moment où j'ai
accouché j'avais couché j'ai fait
demi-tour dans ma voiture j'allais en
studio j'ai fait demi tour je suis allée
accoucher
je suis revenue deux mois après pour
travailler mais je me souviens très bien
parce que ça évidemment me l'a pas dit
au moma à ce jour là on l'a dit à
benjamin qui m'a répété ce que c'est un
bon c'est mon copain mais lorsque je
suis j'étais en état de revenir ce que
j'ai voulu revenir très vite j'ai fait
un déjeuner avec un patron dont je
tairai le nom le calme
voilà lequel patron en fait tu faisais
le déjeuner non pas pour savoir si
j'étais heureux aussi tout allait bien
mais pour vérifier que j'avais bien
retrouver ma silhouette et pour être
certaine que je n'étais pas simplement
une mère complètement dingue de son
nourrisson mais une animatrice capable
de reprendre le boulot
donc voilà c'est la réalité c'est pas
grave c'est le monde du travail
il se trouve que le monde du travail
celui que je connais c'est la télévision
mais ça paraît ce sera peut-être par
examen comptable ou pareil pour un
géricault stade
alors on s'est dit que notre expérience
personnelle je vous appréciera alors si
tu es là aussi vous étiez puis quoi vous
caser avait gagné énormément d'un mois
j'ai alors bon c'est pas moi la question
mais moi je vois une chose moi j'ai
jamais j'ai toujours dit dans ce métier
c'est comme tout le métier où on n'est
pas ami avec tout le monde voilà moi
j'ai pas beaucoup d'amis dans ce métier
j'ai pas exactement quand j'ai pu boulot
le téléphone et ce n'est pas plus pas
moins mais c'est vrai que moi quand on
mar après pour les autres sur ces huit à
dix huit mois crée plus de boulot et je
s'était d'ailleurs c'est lui qui m'a
appelé trois que c'est vous dire
et je vous ai dit je ne sais pas
pourquoi vous m'appeliez ce n'est qu'en
fait je me demandais pourquoi me
rappeler qu'effectivement je me suis
habitué très vite mais c'est vrai que
c'est simple it et le pourquoi ces
entités parce que le gâteau il n'est pas
il n'est pas extensible monde il ya peu
de demandes pour un plan pour un petit
gâteau
donc effectivement on veut toujours
c'est souvent la place de l'autre on se
fait pas de cadeaux est ce que vous
trouvez que le monde de la télé est un
monde
voilà où il ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie
bien que ça beaucoup de gens sincères
non ya déjà neuf
je n'irai pas dans le sens parce que
c'est pas vrai il n'ya pas que des cons
avec des mineurs mais effectivement
c'est un milieu extrêmement durs ou des
places sont extrêmement chères et il
sait place tout le monde les envies donc
dès qu'on peut vous en mettre une dr la
tête
on voulait mais c'est vrai que quand on
est moisi écologiquement c'est dur oui
bien sûr que c'est dur mais moi si je
vous dis pourquoi je vous me fassiez des
séries et c'est pour ça que je vous
adore ce que vous avez vous vécu pendant
quinze ans vous étiez le plus mauvais je
n'ai jamais loin quel plus beau le plus
mauvais le pen la plus moche le mot
rose et verte et le chameau mais
attention on est bon pour l'ambiance
était de finir lombez à enchaîner
s'enchaîner bon match dans la gueule il
était drôle à marcher allez on disait
hanouna c'est un chat noir elle est
drôle dénommé qu'à fuir
et ce qui me fascine c'est que quand
vous avez le pouvoir et le retour de
bâton bum à des onze en profiter mais de
façon très saine
c'est formidable parce que c'est une
vengeance absolue et vous avez été très
loin et c'est magnifique
et les mêmes qui disent il est pas beau
il est nul il pas drôle les mêmes il
vous sert les pompey est encore les
pompes c'est peu et voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour tous et tous ces mecs initie les
pompes qu'il appelle et on voit les
voeux alors qu'il en fait soyez donc au
début parce qu'en fait ils ont plus de
production sur la chaîne vasisht aussi à
l'epo cera
vous nous venger tous voila merci
beaucoup c'est vous remercie du fond du
coeur
et le nom de
mon plaisir d'avoir été en place
notamment réfuté le real a payé à la
payer cash d'avoir des violences hélas
dans cette mairie des absences côtoient
back aux députés la halle a payé cash
et c'est vrai que c'est un milieu très
dur mais voilà mais heureusement série 2
à venger parce que vous dire que ce qui
lui cire les pompes c'est les mêmes qui
l'enfonçaient il ya dix ans bonsoir oui
dans leur sang sur un point c'est
d'autant plus dur que le public aussi
juge moi comment même c'est ça on
appelle ça nous on essaie aussi de
rendre de temps de mon micro aux gens et
vous avez les mois les lettres des
téléspectateurs je les lis tout le temps
et ça dit mais virer le mais il est
moche mais il aimait aussi mêlé cela et
ça joue dans certains cas quand ça
devient trop abîmée salie zahi l'enisa
va pas s'en plaindre on a six ménages
mais il a lui aussi grave mais ça s'est
avéré que les milieux tout court et dur
moi je les suis je connais les gens qui
vont au sein des groupes mondialistes
c'est épouvantable et eux n'ont pas le
recours d'avoir une antenne médiatique
pour s'expliquer quand ça va pas moi
j'ai envie d'avoir la zesa moquer
complètement extérieur rémois food mc
phee d'auto dérision c'est pas mal à ça
tous super l'aspect c'est pas des
conneries ça s'est passé
moi c'est mon chéri aurais je rappelle
que raymond et les chauffeurs doivent
même ans il est chauffeur livreur et
raymond c'est vrai que mon raymond doit
arriver dans la télé le mine de rien tu
découvres un milieu pour toi est ce que
le monde de la télé est cruel bah ouais
il est il est surtout ils sont
hypocrites basescu
parce que cruel c'est partout en fait
savoir tout et moi je rejoins valérie
quand tu vas alors je mets en dehors des
techniciens les agents de sécurité
maquillage et les coiffeuses je les mets
en dehors du monde à la télé je parle de
ceux qui sont dans les boîtes de prod et
qui sont sous les projecteurs ils savent
où ils mettent les pieds
il avait peut-être des aptitudes pour
aller dans d'autres sociétés il avait
envie de faire ça tu sais on ne sait
tous on le sait tous que c'est cruel que
les licenciements ils vont être
peut-être dur on le sait tous
après je pense que le monde moi le monde
j'allais dire la vraie vie le monde dans
l'entreprise aussi parce que la télé
c'est la vraie vie le monde dans
l'entreprise il est encore plus cruel
parce que moi j'écoute je côtoie les
deux les deux nids mais en ce moment je
côtoie les deux et les gens
d'entreprises sur des gens de la télé et
parfois j'entendais boîte de prod batave
ils ont viré jérémy au bout de trois ans
ils lui ont donné combien 50000 euros
waouh 40000 euros cinquante mille euros
prennent leur temps mais si c'est vrai
syrie de ta gueule tu as déjà eu affaire
à bien sûr les contentieux se nomme me
dis pas que tu as jamais donné quarante
mille euros à quelqu'un car avec deux
ans de boîte moi j'ai gérard qui peut
plus conduire parce qu'il a mal au dos
38 ans doit-il après 9000 euros 38
endroit exact c'est à dire que la télé
moi je veux bien mais vous savez où vous
mettez les pieds et une fois de plus il
a des mises au placard je pensais bien
et chabot d'eau qui a fait des chiffres
aux mines ils l'ont laissé 15 ans
olivier chabot olivier charles
millionnaire exemple par exemple et 15
ans il reste à tf1 où il a pris ses
salaires il venait juste le matin pour
se présente bien sûr à l'heure mais le
l'obs un super mec oui mais ça a super
aqmi et moi je dis que voilà pour finir
ce que j'ai pas la science infuse
je pense que la télé c'est surtout
hypocrite je pense mathieu alors
j'essaie d'aller vite c'est dur pour toi
makyo pas dit la vérité moi deux choses
la venoge ce que toi tu as eu des hauts
et des bas m'ont battu à brême et moi je
vais vous dire parce que encore une fois
pardon mais ceux qui parlent sont
toujours ceux qui savent pas devant ce
que tu dis sur l'entreprise s'est pas dû
à la télé dans les entreprises et chez
france télécom ou n'importe quoi tu as
25 en cdi quand tu pars tu pars avec un
gros chèque c'est pas dieu l'a terrassé
l'entreprise mais aussi sa maîtresse à y
avoir et savoir de ma vie je savais
c'était dur la célébrité et après et le
voir mais moi je peux te dire qu'à
recommencer ce métier je le recommence
pas non c'est vrai mathieu et pour bien
sur quoi pour attendre mathieu auteur de
minutes c'est preque je m'arrête de
zones là dessus sur elle si on devait te
dire voilà la tâte un choix à faire
je ne ferai pas
tous les mobiles devrait plus être à
l'antenne c'est ce que j'aime les gens
et j'aurais fait un métier je le dis
j'aime bien les jeux de voiture et
j'aurais fait un métier pour avoir une
très jolie confort de vie peut-être
monter un resto une salle de sport et
tout mais je ne serais pas allé dans la
célébrité pourquoi si j'avais su pas
parce que je me rends compte que j'ai eu
ça me correspond pas tellement je vis
ils étaient jugés tout le temps tu es tu
critiquais tout le temps tu es tu es tu
es tu n'as pas de vie tu ne peux pas
sortir avec ça me fait du mal
un petit peu j'adore passer du temps
avec vous mes skis aujourd'hui les
inconvénients pour moi sont bien
supérieurs à ce que vous dites à
nazareth 30 à une table et tout ça côté
un peu de pognon tue l'est aussi
moi je te disant que voilà non que je
vous racontais parce que dans quel dans
quelle entreprise
on peut être licencié en une minute sur
un sondage
et bien moi j'ai eu ça moi nrj12 et si
nous regarde notre ami vincent broussard
qu'il était venu directeur général et ça
faisait six ans que j'étais à nrj 12 une
fois que tu es un génie mais si ça
marche et ça marchait très bien et un
jour au mois de juin une côte dans son
bureau et il me dit cher mathieu je vais
changer la chaîne il ya trop de télé
réalité je veux qu'elle ait du sens tu
es le symbole de ce que je ne veux plus
alors tu dégages
il savait pas que tu faisais un métier
d'image je vous jure on avait laissé le
shérif répondu allemand mais monsieur le
directeur il ajouté est en général je me
suis laissé un message c'est plus dur ou
moi je peux changer puis jeudi il me dit
vous n'avez pas louer tutelle pas vu le
coup arriver bajus dit non je dois être
un peu et de jauge et l'hymne de la télé
réalité
il m'a dit de fait non je suis parti
avec 000 d'indemnités pas de prud'hommes
révèle contraire ce qu'on m'a dit si tu
attaques
ça sort a et aura toutes les chaînes à
dos maintenant ce sera le monsieur
procédurier je suis parti avec 0 pas un
euro
j'avais que des cdd mais se retrouver
dans la rue le première chose que j'ai
faite si j'appelais mon pote fogiel et
lui dit qu'est ce que je fais et m'a dit
vente à bagnols je te jure que c'est
vrai et la semaine d'après bam ya le
tunisien qui m'appellent
[Rires]
désolé
les olé c'est hélas
fini qu'on ne veut plus parce que je
sais de télé rythme tu as fait donc sur
un sondage été virés to play alors c'est
pas si simple
voilà c'est pas si ça mathieu temps at
on a souffert de la blessure
vraiment oui vraiment c'est vrai je
promets je je je je d'abord je n'ai pas
le talent des drucker et de tout ça si
le sénat il en meurt alors je te le dis
mais c'est sûr qu'à 60 ans je sois pas
la télé je te le redis pour moi tu as
largement le talon de deux des dix plus
grands animateurs comme hebbadj est ce
que tu m'as dit un jour très gentiment
mais parlez moi c'est ridicule parce que
l'on parlait de dechavanne c'est
important oui mon gars jouent on était
avant vegas et tu m'as dit je pense que
tu as que tu as beaucoup de talent mais
tu as tu n'as pas de morale du sportif
qui va avec et c'est vrai que parfois je
les ai vus avec vous par exemple quand
ça commence à taper que ça tape fort et
à toute la presse contre toi que sa part
est en a eu des histoires tout le csa
les matins les halles qu'elle finalise
faut tenir pas déclencher de maladie et
tout ça moi c'est vrai que je pense que
j'ai pas le mental assez fort j'ai voilà
j'ai tellement j'ai le mental pour aller
en demi finale mais pour l amphi là il
faut vraiment tenir et je pense que
peut-être un peu trop fragile tout ça
moi pour moi c'est dur donc si j'avais
le choix je serai les behrami lyon gagne
très bien sa vie j'ai rouvert un resto
parce que oui j'aime bien une belle vie
mais là mais la célébrité je pense qu'on
la veut puis quand on en sait plus très
bien qu en [ __ ] vous avez peur aussi
même pour votre famille tout ça ça vous
ça vous a fait mais ça fait souffrir
votre famille bien sûr mais pour ses
obsèques et puis en plus je l'aï vérité
parce que mon père et c'est un autre
chose ils voulaient se passe des choses
peut-être père est avocat on va
différents voilà peut-être un peu plus
d'infos je ne sais pas quoi
et puis c'est vrai tout ce que j'ai vécu
j'ai fait une dépression et puis ma
voiture été vandalisée plus tu dis un
truc sur les gilets jaunes autres achats
la gale et puis tu dis un mot ou d'une
façon tatin du pognon bas pardon raymond
sélection donne son avis en soit été
animateur ferme ta gueule tu es du
pognon à sa mémoire est à mon sens
immense mois sur dix ans ici je vais
rendre mon petit ne me correspond plus
je reconnais que dans tous les cas cette
télé d'aujourd'hui ne vous correspond
plus tellement vous êtes quand même
euros avec nous pas évidemment que j
aurai avec vous c'est vrai que la
célébrité
j'ai couru après et maintenant j'ai
tendance avec mes neveux et tous ceux
qui sont là plus tôt alors allez gérer
je le dis je le dis franchement je
faisais peut-être me contredire mais
c'est vrai que nous on est un petit peu
le village gaulois
sur ces 8 on est vraiment à part on fait
vraiment notre vie à part d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on a énormément béni vous le
savez vous avez vu un c'est vrai qu'on
est un petit village vraiment on est une
chaîne voilà qui tandis qu'une chaîne
voilà une bonne petite chaîne mais voilà
c'est à dire mais on a même des groulx a
qui essayait voilà deux de nous deux
ou de nous noyer n'oublie pas ce qu'on
aime dans notre terre mine de rien et on
est un petit village d'irréductibles ont
gagné à chausser ses défauts gel qui
veulent et c'est là vers saint denis
cotte et patron d'une boutique parce que
j'ai pas les vices les jeans le marx et
le 500 m marche plus bon tu vas faire de
502 quand et animateur ta marque c'est
tour - quand tu te réveilles le matin et
que tu te prends un four d'audience
monumental c'est pas ta marque n'a pas
marché c'est toi c'est ta blessure
narcissique tu te lèves en te disant on
ne m'aime pas et les gens te disent il
ya eu un rejet il va rejet de toi la
courbe baisse quand tu parles tout ça je
l'a entendu parfois la courbe baisse
quand tu parles quand l'animateur du
travail le matin tu prends une taule
mais tout on ta journée entière on est
pour vous connaissez plus ça mais la
journée entière mathieu béjot
il ya des gens qui vont vous dire
également le cheveu chez l'ogre vous
dire moi si je suis vendeur de voiture
je vois pas une voiture
forcément alors attendez là si
j'aimerais avoir l'avis de géraldine et
moi en fait le camp du oui je les
trouvais extrêmement nuance est
extrêmement pertinent sans misérabilisme
et effectivement je je vois là je suis
absolument d'accord avec ce qu'ils
disent et nous magie les justes ouais
non mais justement j'étais dans le
compte du nom donc pour le coup ils
m'ont ils m'ont quand même convaincu
voulais dire à raymond bon raymond c'est
pas parce que nous on travaille à la
télévision et qu'on est peut-être des
dentiers qu'on est effectivement très
favorisés qu'on connaît pas des gens
dans nos familles qui ont des retraites
qui sont chômage qui galèrent genou
aussi renommés se dire on est aussi
confronté à sarko on n'est pas que
déconnecté de ce réel là et de cette
difficulté là donc voilà ça c'est une
première chaude et des comédiens non
n'est pas déconnecté nous voir l'équipe
devant le monde de lanton a obligé la
grille est ce que tu veux dvg m c'est
fou on a déconné mais la chine comme son
grand mère qui est un tout petit c'est
parce qu'il est sûre qu'est ce que c'est
que vie mais je le vis plus que c'est ma
grand mère c'est pas le débat oui la
phrase mais non mais non on parie 17
qu'on était déconnecté ou pas est en
revanche moi je trouve qu'effectivement
c'est un monde impitoyable parce qu'en
fait on est dans une blessure
narcissique
voilà effectivement mathieu l'a très
bien dit ce que parce qu'en fait le
métier et aussi sur son ego sur sa
gueule sur sa pomme et effectivement on
est pas on n'est pas déconnecté de sa
réussite ou pas en fait compétents tels
le samedi matin
personne même de tpm people julien
franchement un exemple quand j'ai un
carton de matin y compris toi je sais
que le matin je sais si ça marche et si
g19 sms je sais que j'ai eu un succès
quand j'en ai un
c'est où toi ou producteurs juste
j'ai pris une tôle ya plus personne
n'est pas mince il n'y a plus perdu la
raison ou pas la raison samedi je vais
vous dire moi il avait une grande est
des fous mal à passer grande traversée
du désert mais c'est vrai que moi je ne
bronchait même plus aux portes à toute
façon personne n'a rappelé
donc je joue à la playstation toutes les
régions à la ps4 moi je dit à son père
sound appelé je suis ta comme moi je
suis bien majeur oui juste wizo alors
une chose c'est vrai que le matin quand
le téléphone sonne pas à 9h02 aux ja
9h03 alors la face avant l'été
spectateurs les audiences avec la 9
heures
voilà pourquoi n'est appliquée sur
christophe camilla me soigne une chose
très forte avec pt que quand j'étais sur
le m6 les lofts marché très fort pour
moi l'une était un peu dans un trou il
m'appelait tout le temps on travaille
ensemble et puis quand il est revenu et
claude lafortune et ben il m'a plu
appelé on sait plus appelez donc c'est
vrai que la styliste un taux qui n'a
jamais d'accord mais on peut pas
reprocher après aux autres et après
faire ce qu'on a fait effectivement moi
j'ai essayé dans ma carrière je pense
que d'abord les mêmes amis même constat
à léo et c'est pourquoi ils pourraient
venir mais mathieu de ne pas changer de
comportement entre man ou sa marche
glorieuse marche pas et j'ai pensé à une
fierté et je peux vous dire je n'ai
jamais changé que je sois tout en haut
bon bah voilà les valérie voulu ajouter
quelques jolis noms je voulais
simplement revenir sur ce que disait
mathieu qui me semble très juste et que
par exemple si tu te plantes dans une
entreprise sur un bilan comptable je
prends un hasard une comptable elle
pourrait se plante sur son bilan
comptable on va pas remettre en cause sa
personne on va remettre ça mais c'est
sur glace bien sûr que j rv à remettre
en cause son d'adhésion de la team des
chiffres des communes s'est fait masser
schiste fait de virer bien sûr une
émission on va dire que c'est toi
intrinsèquement et parce qu'elle ne se
cautionne tuer qui n'est pas parce que
celui-ci dans le vert de la vie que la
télé ni survie
les policiers de postes mais on a su
site par les agriculteurs
évidemment que la question c'est c'est
pas est-ce que c'est plus pénible non
l'animateur télé vous être un policier
non666 un peu ça normalement d'une
erreur vache à lait sur radio tout
pardon réponse que souvent vous
comparaissez comme qu'on débat s'il
conduisait son quand il faut bien
comparé au reste ce n'est pas son style
manquera jamais comparer les souffrances
et ce qu'on disait aussi pour la shoah
pour nice ne comparez pas les suites
rend ce sont des souffrances
donc là on n'est pas prêt à dire c'est
tout croquer la police hors jeu rennais
on parle de l'atce répond alors relevé
lors de la keynote mouvement même si
rennes est reconnue aussi je te dise
tout ça quand tu as quelqu'un qui te
convoque dans son bureau ça nous est
tous arrivé et qu'il te dis pardon de te
le dire il ya eu un rejet de table ces
maps and shake prochaine l'émission et
rejette à personne je serais tu sors du
bureau rappeler à tous que tu as ton
copain ton copain qui avec toi tu donc
dans mon cas le copain qui avec toi
toute la journée tu fais la gueule il le
support 100 séjours il s'était mis ce
bar parce qu'il en a marre d'être avec
quelqu'un où tout est axé sur lui c'est
compliqué durée avec quelqu'un dont la
marque c'est soi-même
pardon mais même vous dire tu le vis
vous dire sur scène austère questions
portent ces métiers un jour à la vie de
révolte quand on choisit ce métier là ce
métier d'être devant la télé ou d'être
même succès nous au cinéma on a les
inconvénients et on a les avantages un
vendeur de voiture s'ils vont pas sa
voiture bien sûr c'est pas tout le monde
dans la rue que va nous dire ah t'as pas
vendu ta voiture voilà c'est fait c'est
vrai que ce que dit mathieu je le vois
dans ses yeux parce que là ils trichent
pas assez et c'est vrai que ça te remets
pas où ça tourne en question même ta
personne
oui tu dis que tu as raté ta super tu as
souffert des fois non moi je sais pas
moi j'ai eu un an et demi où j'ai rien
fait mais moi c'est pas pareil moi
j'écris mes trucs mais ça mois des jeux
ça m'a pas j'écris des spectacles sa
branche ça marche pas j'en fais un autre
et puis j'écris j'écris j'écris ce que
disait tout à l'heure
benjamin à ton égard justement moi j'ai
connu cyril à cette époque là je connais
cyril avait personne dans la salle on
était deux mois le régisseur tripes et
pour moi c'est vrai et c'est vrai que la
chance les pilotes le talent et les
folies c'est extraordinaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui il est au top
il n'a pas obligé il n'a pas oublié les
potes qui est avec lui qu'on n'était pas
au top sur toi et ça c'est très
important c'est vrai que on peut pas
comparer quelqu'un qui vend des voitures
à quelqu'un qui passait et que ses
phalanges équipés
vous donnez moi les cours gratuits à
nrj12 hamon qui m'appelle les gens et
c'est horrible à mon petit niveau je
fais pas partie que sabatier mais tu
dises bas alors êtes-vous côte est ce
que vous revenez vous faites quoi
et toi comme thor dieu qu'est ce que tu
dis je prépare des trucs sur un gros
projet dans ta tête tu sais que ta
personne mais alors j'ai pas fini il va
dire qu'au journal à cette marche ils
m'énervent ou d'ailleurs laissé filer au
but et après ça on revient souvent à
l'argent parce que tout le monde connait
beaucoup d'argent et tout mais l'argent
à un moment donné ça fait pas tout quand
je marche dans la rue ça fait beaucoup
quand même un nom voici mes biens soit
tu marches dans la rue et que tout le
monde te déteste ça me freine aussi
contribué vrai nom est la raison d'être
est séduit le ciel ou de coups et les
gens n'osent reprise qui son choix ben
oui les façons je ne peux pas dire non
quand même pas dire leur famille aux
amis et la télévision que si tu mets une
fouille la question est ce que le grès
ou parcours vite se compare pas aux
animaux tu t'en sais rien ses convives
pour l'accompagner chez moi je finisse
comme ça au calcul ce projet nous
aujourd'hui
d'accord ça je suis d'accord mais les
gens et calcule pas des années de galère
qu'on a une telle galère avant au tarif
un spectacle the jam n'était pas marrant
on m'a dit dégage ça a duré 15 ans pour
plein de gens attendant les autres
matches si on calcule que ce qu'on gagne
mais aujourd'hui les gens vous dire moi
je la refuse j'aimerais j'aimerais
tourner vers kelly françois thierry
serrés vous avez été mine de rien sous
les feux des projecteurs édenté pmp jour
loin est ce que pour vous aujourd'hui
c'est dur ou pas la célébrité le monde
de la télé est ce qui vous semble dur ou
pas du tout bah moi je sais pas trop si
je peux m'exprimer à ce sujet parce que
j'ai été j'ai quand même été choyé quand
je suis arrivé ici j'ai pas connu
d'autre d'autres chaînes d'autres
émissions donc pour moi tout se passe
super bien et je vois et pour moi ça a
été plus dur avant que ici à l'antenne
donc j'ai
j'ai vu que le monde du travail et été
honnête dans l'émission soit honnête et
tellement touchante qu'il il ya eu des
soirs où il ya des choses difficiles
qu'on intègre bien c'est à pleurer dans
mes bras et tout passe quelque chose
c'est difficile de prendre des coups
quand même oui c'est difficile mais ces
choses comme d'autres travail ou dans
lesquels j'ai travaillé a rejeté au
figaro je pleurais par exemple j'ai même
des bons je me suis fait engueuler alors
j'aimerais j'aimerais parler aussi
maintenant à répond l'un des coups dans
la région vous aurez pour moi je prends
pour à toi toi aussi tu es devenu
célèbre du jour le nom je suis pas
célèbre ici notre attaque a bien marché
avec l'âge dans la rue tu verras que les
renards mais tu sais pas si c'est pas la
question c'est pas la question mais
neige que toi je me sens est ce que tu
as été déboussolé par le fait que tu
sois devenu célèbre
mais non mais non mais si c'est ce que
les gens te regardent et et pnt raymond
quand même bah oui laconique je sais pas
j'ai pas été déboussolé pour la simple
et bonne raison que moi j'ai continué a
beau aimer mais je suis sûr et c'est
dans le truc c'est parce que tu as pris
le melon j'ai pas été si la vérité je
penser par moi de dire si j'ai fait non
je peux moi je suis sûr d'une chose est
sûre le regard des gens je vous dirais
que c'est pas regarder chose je veux
dire une chose c'est que le truc ou que
moi j'ai pris beaucoup de choses à coeur
c'est ici dans les débats j'ai pris
peut-être trop à coeur et notamment la
saison dernière j'ai pris des trucs à
coeur mais vraiment à paris droit tu
m'as recadrer après tu m'a reparlé tu
m'expliquer tu m'as dit voilà il faut
pas te faut pas non plus divisée que ces
tares et c est ça va beaucoup mieux
moi je vous dis je vais vous le dire
pour moi ici c'est une récré je fais des
remboursements anticipés
dès que je peux m'en aller d'ici je
m'embête c'est un jeu ici moi je voulais
faire de la radio avec toi grâce grâce à
je viens depuis j'ai fait de la radio
avec toi maintenant moi si je suis pas
chroniqueur onfray je viens et je rigole
ici je pas chroniqueur je comprends ce
que dit mathieu mais ce que dilma dessus
avec mais bien qu'au 2e mathieu il est
bien ce que dit mathieu joue
la voix des sages alors on veut on peut
faire un truc très simple je l'avais
payé c'est normal je suis bien payé par
rapport à mon métier de chauffeur
livreur
mais je suis sûr qu ici c'est moi le
moins payé bien ici que pour envoyer ses
prêts non ça n'a pas l'air ça les
salaires je vais vous dire les salaires
les salaires sont faits en fonction de
l'ancienneté dans l'ancienneté voilà
qu'un de ces malades la carrière la
koala mais c'est vrai que toi mais pour
répondre à mathieu quand ils 19h02
machin c'est ma personne c'est ma
personne mathieu sait qu'une crise d'ego
tu le sais très bien parce que la caisse
et je veux pas que je veux pas comparer
mais la caissière quand tu lui manque
dix balles dans sa quête c'est qu'elle
se féminise
c'est une question d'ego megève d'isoler
la monnaie reçue par et vous allez voir
ça continue à fonctionner le monde de la
télévision
est il trop dur c'est vrai que là ça
s'enflamme valérie benaïm disent
répondre répondra à raymond therese quoi
quand il quand il visait à l'instant à
mathieu le matin à 9 heures quand tu
prends une tôle d'audience à 1 au
contraire un shoot de beurre parce que
ça fonctionne très bien c'est une
question d'ego c'est pas simplement
qu'une question d'ego c'est que tu sais
que ta carrière elle se joue là à la
dépense est lent départ oui c'est à dire
que au delà du fait que oui tu peux tu
peux tu peux être gonflé d'orgueil en
disant formidable regarde comme je fais
des sus une chose formidable ou à l
inverse de dire aux gars comme je suis
une mère tu es incapable d'avoir une
émission qui fonctionne au-delà de ça
être ça une vraie conséquence c'est que
la conséquence est que le lendemain ou
le surlendemain 6 1 6 2 jours de suite
trois jours d'essais depuis l'émission
si ça n'était pas très ce que tu vois
dans les autres entreprises n'est pas
sujet des résultats au monde et pas de
succès restent jamais bien travaillé a
bien peindre à bien distribuer le
courrier à avoir des résultats
l'allemand qui sont en train de dire
c'est qu'elle est en train de dire que
tu n'as rien la même chose sauf
l'arrogance des animateurs la même
source arrivé à quelqu'un mais si c'est
dans un autre entreprise je t'ai ce que
j'ai dit en train de dire si des
sanctions sont travail mal m dont les
autres une sanction si elles menacées
par la question certaines allégations
d'un coup pas la question pour x raisons
et rejeter et mac os x pour x raisons
les gens n'achètent pas la voiture côté
son c'est comme ça mais je ne comprends
pas j'ai envie d'aller là bas c'est que
tu n'es libre de rien je vais te donner
un exemple une fois basse est arrivé à
benjamin aussi tu fais un excellent
année un excès de vitesse sur
l'autoroute je te promets que c'est vrai
à nrj12 ils sont venus me voir en me
disant je te préviens un truc comme ça
ça pour la ménagère ça veut dire le mec
il est animateur il peut rouler vite
parce qu'ils se la pète pour nous c'est
très mauvais pour les publicitaires et
d'ailleurs on peut dans les cages que tu
viens dans quelle personne un devoir
il fallait cette duchesse était un
excellent il serait que tu le fais rien
tombola veut dire la perte du mal je
vais dire que les juges aient tout temps
sur un sondage il à énergie faisait 3 et
va l'arrêter pour mathieu dans le nord
matthieu à marseille mathieu il en
faisait trois ans que je voudrais pour
dire regardez les résultats compris les
déos moi j'ai décidé d au moins mathieu
9 fois sur 10 quand animateur télé tout
arrêter pour une et excès de vitesse le
journal tenu à en croire les sondages ne
regardez pas ouf
avec mes mecs même quand tu te fais
arrêter les avantages sont ultra là
c'est toi qui dit que tout était
sanctionné ou travail d'antanimena où je
vous enverrai gérard je rappelais de
biava une erreur tu peux perdre deux
matches pour faire les mineurs du pack
ajoutera valoir que s'il ya un pv saisi
avec un flic et un pv je le prends au
naturel s'il vous plaît aujourd'hui je
vous dire ça c'est un petit peu changé
on l'a vu encore cette semaine avec les
réseaux sociaux vous avez vu que le
jeune homme qui est venu nous voir
adama cissé qui d'une voix pour un une
photo qui a été prise et qui a été mise
sur les réseaux sociaux
il s'est fait également viré donc
aujourd'hui tout le monde est un petit
passage à la réponse est parce que je
comprends que l'un d'entre eux propose
ses pages et que j'entends bien mais ce
que je comprends pas dans ton propos
mathieu c'est que tu nous expliques il
ya deux minutes que si tu avais pu faire
autre chose dans ta vie un restaurant
une baby sitter attendait écoute lui bah
j'espère que je suis entrain de dos en
train de le dire l'arrêt il a dit à deux
minutes que si cette affaire il ne
ferait pas ensuite il nous dit qu'il a
travaillé six ans chez nrj 12 ont
concédé avec un contrat mais avait
pendant six ans pas 1500 euros par mois
dans l'avé l'occasion de ouvrir son
restaurant ou de changer de vie puisque
tu es tu es dedans et on a menacé en
disant si tu vas aux prud'hommes
tu feras plus jamais de télé et toi t'as
rien dit et partitas paix tomé aidantes
et aidants la rue raynal et madame ça
j'allais changer l'âme est donc en vue
de la hat dont on joue de la lumière
mais c'est la paix local un entraîneur
ne les choisis dans les choix de métier
ces mesures ad non mais tu peut pas
décréter je vais pourquoi je vais faire
des passes que ça c'est sans cesse en
témoigne sa passe est un crédit qu'il ya
des gens de ta famille tu chacun parfois
tu es les enfants que tu as cucq up ou
parfois ça peut être des parents
entretien tout d'un coup tu avais des
pussy libre pour nous qu'à chaque fois
qu'un garçon a fait virer serait
toujours à chaque fois qu'un cas se fait
virer de son travail il retourne à la
télé vont forcément mais demain je fais
ni conte aura fini de rembourser son
emprunt et je te souhaite le plus vite
possible en france n'a mis le doigt dans
quelques dans le décor dolto pas encore
tiendra on te proposera une émission
mais type de terrain je la prendrai pas
tu sais pas non mais ils sont par
tradition c'est ce que je sais moi je
m'amuse ici je fais des roseaux des
remboursements anticipés j'étais à 1100
je suis descendu et nous sur scène je
récuse année et peut-être même qu'au
mois de juin
et bien sûr vous êtes de loi vous pouvez
pas dire ça à mon avis appelé les civils
par les mâles un manque de respect pour
l'être il ya des retards sont peut-être
attaché à vous on ne peut pas dire je ne
sais pas c'est parce que je dis c'est
pas dans les séries je me fais d'abord
je n'aurais pas autant de pognon je dis
juste que je ne suis pas fait pour la
télé je ne suis pas faire ma casse toi
au dîner parfait bourg il dit je vais
faire du pognon là non il vient donner
quelque chose change et des rôles à la
télé est fatigué tout ça est trop tôt et
vous fatiguez tous parce qu est ce que
vous dites cela n'aide pas car tout
entier est vrai et moi ça fait des
années que j'écoute des gens qui me
parlent de leurs malheurs en télé
auxquelles je compatis honnêtement mais
en revanche j'imagine tous les gens qui
nous écoutent qui vivent un quotidien
mais
[Applaudissements]
c'est le dieu d'amour et valérie musée y
aurait une bonne fois pour toutes il n'y
a pas danger qu'on vient de dire les
danses passé il n'y a pas atteint je
terminais bordel lorsque je viens de
dire ici il n'ya pas de complaintes
tenant dans l'eau par onze on a pu nous
a posé une question répond à mes amis
mais de ce que l'on connaît bien sûr on
nous a demandé d'être cachés on nous a
dit la vérité delà du métier que l'on
connaît donc vie on ne dit pas le
contraire on est on ne dit pas qu'on est
triste et malheureuse
on est là on le fait on est heureux de
le faire mais simplement il m'a posé la
question
par ailleurs on ne dit pas qu'on est
mieux ou moins bien que le métier de
coach et on est en train d'entendre
avons bien sages ils ont mon métier
il est que vous me demander comment il
est je vous le dis sur la table comment
il est maintenant j'ai décidé d'y rester
donc je prends le bon et je prends le
mauvais match on va te salon je dirais
non enfin mathieu mathieu ça la range de
dire qu'il faut pas comparer que ces
terrains est alors ta conseille de vous
comme pour les pv en disant quand
animateurs de tavaux exemple vous écoute
pas je disais avant les inconvénients
des gens pas connu autant de boulets et
je vous laisse les privilèges des gens
conduisent alors qu'ils y ont goûté
téléporter désensabler guillaume genton
dommage vous dire que le monde de la
télé ni cruel pour les gens qui sont à
l'antenne aussi les gens qui sont hors
antenne ya des producteurs y avait un
monteur il ya des auteurs qui se
retrouvent au chômage parce qu'une
émission marche pas ça c'est terrible
pour eux et c'est seulement les
audiences qui décide ce qui se passe en
télé ça c'est cruel vous pouvez faire
une super émission qui est au top bien
sûr fait un mauvais score en prime time
vous êtes grillés pour toute une
carrière et ça c'est valable pour les
animateurs et pour les gens ce qu'il
faut trouver des coupables à chappes si
vous vous ça méritait beaucoup mieux que
moi ça y est la saison il faut de sud
assez d'accord allez on va voir les
résultats du sondage
regardez ma pensée parce que c'était
extrêmement houleux alors m oui oui
mais bon il y aura dix jours les chéris